very shortly before christmas there was
peace in our office and there was no
cameraman alone and we talked about his
projects which he really
tries to save the world
at least to make it better and
why he really
could have the skills for that quite considerably  to
contribute this is all coming soon
it made me very thoughtful
suitable for christmas by the way it was
also a fun fact that
some people called me afterwards and
when they wanted to get to know
friedel after a podcast came out for the first time
and i have now found out that
millions flowed into his fund
we are many other listeners so convinced
of the ideas that fridtjof came
forward best of all
welcome in yourself fridtjof detzner
nice to say you are you say we
are a generation a little can
its
hamburg danger  there because there has there but he
started early you're from cuxhaven
and h  actually then in
cuxhaven he started doing things at the age of 16
and let's make progress on the journey
accordingly
yes i founded christa goetsch green
company a longtime partner
christa trio exactly and to be honest
both were at school and rather a
relaxed party asked who
I want to found the company and I raised my
hand and that's how it actually
starts when I'm 16 next to my high school diploma
to build a company and then we
sold very, very old school computers
and made websites for half a year,
the first website then in exchange for a
surfboard  and the second one was
actually paid and so you are
also a developer, yes, yes, christian if
you both like it that you were already
taught in school, so i
think i rather design concepts
minus and then put ideas
later exactly at 2 p.m. and christian
taught himself programming  and
so we really started happening
ok and then that was it  a trip with apple
agency founded back then against cuxhaven
also only then
at some point it first criticism
big things will be the third
in the bunch the math henze here 12
years ago was already a guest who is also with
jimdo now to this day there you are
but what came out before juno,
how did you come about,
to be honest, we then made websites
for other people and then
developed a web application relatively quickly
Back and forth
developed web applications at a
time when not so many
people were doing it and we really
learned a lot. I do
n’t think we earned the money we should have
earned, but it was a
lot of fun, and then we thought about it
at some point  yes okay what is
actually a product that you can
expand and have made us totally
lie now  the people who
had one of our websites put them in a
position to be able to fly it
themselves and that was the
photo pd so in the end a
homepage construction kit you can say
exactly back then and i think that was exciting for
us at the time  we did
n't look left and right at all if you
want you can make it particularly
easy how can you really put people in a
position to maintain their website themselves
and, above all, simply give
small and medium-sized
companies the opportunity
to maintain a website themselves  that
was a time when there were really only
two ways, either you program it
yourself, you hire the agency, i.e.
this way, which has become normal today,
to maintain the website yourself,
there weren’t actually the factors back then
and if there were any, it
was difficult and  we actually
really started from scratch on a blank sheet of paper
and
asked ourselves how ka  nn you feel so good
and it's easy it's
anyone can do it and somewhere so the
power of the internet
to make it accessible to everyone small business owners
okay and that went on for many
years when I had my company there is
one here in hamburg today  the bigger
digital one in the city you can see that's how he knows
jim but you left yes
first made headlines after
18 years yes exactly that was
n't really a good time either so
at some point matze and chris went
into my children's room  big brother
own farm in germany
we worked for two years then
moved to hamburg at some point in 2004 or
five i think exactly and the
company has built up here and
really from him three guys from the
station to now 280 employees exactly
82 or and in the meantime he was the
same  times 101 invested we need
the earlier samba vehicle
european founders fund only with you
again h  bought them back and hunted
on their long journey there on the site
but the collectors are still in there
with the european founders fund exactly 1 1
1 bought out and now us
investors spectra equities and 2015
got in exactly and are super happy to
be honest so things things
moving in the right direction was that
we haven't had an operation so far so
probably have to ask but
still don't take the time for a
homepage construction kit marco
ohnhäuser that means I think we'll just
see all of them I think you've seen
all the products that  digitize things
and manage this shift in
time how can I when I am
cold especially as a small entrepreneur how
can I because one wants to stabilize my business
I maybe have an
actual shop then of course there are
possibilities to
digitize online shop easy to
need exactly the things that the  that
work there and in time we
have  actually also our online
shop very much so offered in a package for
the entire time for one euro per
month so that i can really start an online
shop right away and i
want to be able to participate it's not just a
website online shop exactly so folks
it's a train  ans both in one tree
we would no longer have this
border between what is on the website
an online shop but can
integrate both but it has not
almost started competition yes it is i
think with jimdo we take
special care of really completely  small
company so i would take this state
the first steps a larger
group of people who build up the real business
and then at some point it will be
really big it will change people
is okay too and that is
actually a success for us because the people
then have come so far  have come that you
're taking the next step, so to speak, that's what
the target group sees for us, he's
really the little mare  n companies are a
lot of system to shop
so really making this barrier
very low so that many people
really don't have to
think about it anymore I dare I
do it yes no but really make these
barriers to entry a successful good
professional online shop
easily accessible to many people  do ok so
18 years but then it was somehow like that
i mean 280 people and this whole
journey at some point was worthy
then told yes maybe hear that we
are hard but well i was 18 years i
don't think i was ever away for more than two weeks
just has to  I didn’t study but
after that I built the company next to
my high school diploma and christa matthias
which I was totally fantastic as a travel
I noticed area would like to
do something new
and different again and 18 years with a
topic like me I want to
I just want to do something
else and then you're on a trip around the
world  how exactly it thought i give
a bit of surfing here used to be done
so heike surfing and that was also
a career path that is intended to be
ultimately not pursued because it
was a really good decision because now
i can do it and because i want to and
not because  I have to be precise, but I did
it a bit and then got
a very
unusual offer. A
friend of mine heard that he was leaving
the operative
business and then he asked me if
I could imagine
doing a tv show a tv show
a long-distance view that i would like to know
the idea was that a german founder
travels the world and
meets other founders worldwide and a
ten-part documentary sale and that's exactly
when i suddenly have
a tv show that's exactly how i first
replied
to the deutsche welle
made precisely because it is it is that
are
maybe also short thought they make  n
quite a lot quite a lot of television
but it is broadcast abroad
for all the citizens
abroad quite well maybe a
small version of
wbc exactly and i was just as naive about
it but after
18 years you have websites now with a camera team
120 days  to fly through the world and
meet other reasons
and we met that again exactly there
were a lot of very inspiring
founders who are a bit on the
threshold right from startup to
scale up so these and are
really about to get started and what else
I think  so say, for
example, any under water i was
with you was in mongolia i'm going
there there are german founders not
german but international
like me as a total of 1 founder then
just really
met founders in mongolia
they have therefore just scaled up  exactly
and I think that one should add
is something that was very
interesting or something  I then suddenly worked with
five journalists from Deutsche
Welle, of course we
had never done it before. It was super interesting
and we thought, hey, how can
we actually make it more interesting, how
can we take ten episodes thematically to the
individual episodes
and probably  if
i wouldn't talk a little bit first
maybe later i would
n't have made this trip because we
said leave ten of the 5 p.m.
sustainability goals as ten in
brackets for the individual episodes
and so i was in an incredible
number of countries but you have to if you  the
solution of a founder, for example, to
climate change global warming
wants to benefit must also show the problem
and that's why this trip can
also be an example by just a
lot more blatant than i think i
originally thought so it's
something i have  a founder produces
the him in d  he mongolia
exports natural cosmetics products all over the
world so it was about
globalization then in hong
kong we shot
urbanization so housing for every hong kong thorsten city in
the world incredibly high pensions so
could renz
exactly and as a result a very precarious
housing situation for many people  who live in
such a divided apartment and all of a sudden
I found myself in
situations that I
had previously
been in his room a little bit all of a sudden there you will
probably always be
second and then you have 17 people who live there with you on
the same floor  to cage
beds therefore hang or can you have
in central india we shot
climate change
what
was the start-up
founder who sort of maybe
tried that problem there was
me basically but
i first interviewed in pharma
in central india he is now
actually trying it  live to
take so because there is a  region that had
the region is even called since if
you can statistically prove the correlation between the
suicide rate of farmers and the
changed weather data
blatantly so and the has from
the ag has tried out of an informed
decision or in protest
or has he not
tried pesticides before
drank
at the ministry of agriculture and then you could pump out your stomach in time
and he survived but he
did it to enable his children to get an orphan’s
pension so he has to
explain how [ __ ] up that actually
is exactly and that’s how the the the
amount of rain there in the  year falls is
actually still the same
but
either heavy rain on some random
days of the year or drought that means the
seed calendars they used that
just didn't work anymore and
didn't meet the founder who
built a kind of greenhouse together with the american university  but a
greenhouse what the te  the temperature doesn't go
up like it does here,
it cools it by seven to eight degrees and also
protects against heavy rain and then you report
the fertilizer with a smartphone on it
that would be somehow if there
are diseases there can send the central office and then
we'll see openly say what to do
and is a very inspiring founder
because he ultimately helps people to
better deal with the consequences of climate change
and i then
spoke to the other driver who
was in there and he promised this
greenhouse gas, which gives my families a
little more stability and has it  then
showed me why it falls
and said if something grows here because that
's an addition this greenhouse that gets
me through ok but that's a blatant
yes of course so you're then on
the one
incredibly desirable but so
to drive through the world  meeting people
is power somehow seeing it doesn't
negotiate higher then you did
with your media product  t that's
already very awesome yes so incredibly
awesome so incredible privilege
to be able to see all that you see
I drove off then you see
problem after problem
after problem so except for
garbage dumps she's a garbage collector
you notice that
children in ulaanbaatar in the  capital
of mongolia have higher cancer rates
because everyone heats with coal and the
heavy metals collect near the ground
so you look at problem after problem
and at some point you start not
seeing the individual problems anymore but
actually recognizing the patterns, i.e.
this term externalization
society  is more just i
think i understood on this
trip but the bad working
conditions to dangerous
working conditions is badly paid
or leads to environmental
pollution this just exports to other countries
and you you understand so you so
you literally understand this sense i think
connections a lot of dollars
when you are there and really talk to the people
and
look at the eyes and hold the realities of life of
these people then also open them up
and when you
are out and about in dhaka in bangladesh and
there in the factories there are rows of kooks or
three days with the child something is going on with
the hammer somehow injection molding sandal
shape hammer just thinking about
shooting well we were always like that ne well
yes it wasn’t easy actually
so we always got visas for all the countries
andré visa I was closed
at the time two passports once a visa entered
here and so that was
right we have already done it intensively and
for example in dakar we have
produced a school that
enables the children to have an hour of
schooling before work, that
means they will then  spread out on a tarpaulin
and then they
teach there, the children come with the
still small children in one  hand
and at least a little bit of instruction is given
and that was ultimately
the door opener i read that i would also have a
look at the factory where i
can see all the material you can
actually see on youtube now he is too
so that means she  whole deutsche
welle and then you have women the weather
is the valley and then there is
exactly i did the first ten
and after the ten i
decided to go in one
direction exactly and that
then became a standard format of
deutsche welle  That means then there
were two or three episodes each, also
with ten people here, other
other founders also asked if they would like
to go on this journey, yes, but to
be honest, it was a
blatant experience for me
personally
[music].
it's for example when
i told this pharma i
come from the farm i think i
grew up quite normally - success
that has given me the
opportunity to
move well in a privileged environment and if i
want to then i can do that and this
trip just showed me all the
underprivileged people as
an example and kicked off the
content so to speak yes you
really do talk to them  and you drive these
realities of life and i was just
lucky enough to be able to work with these five journalists in the
world and that
's just power such a world is also
public law after yes that's
also an expensive project had five
finalists his journey so ok
actually  foreign office paid
and at some point that was what year
2017 would have to follow after these ten follow
after this almost yes media paid
trip around the world wants to go back to hamburg and
thought about what you are doing now yes if i
’m honest it was awesome
to come back again this 120
so meet because you because i can
so in the fullness of this experience  se
that was really overwhelming and
all of a sudden you're back home you're
sitting in a beautiful old building and
you've seen so much in such a short
time and i was already asking myself what
am i going to do now so i'm
aware that you have a prototype  a
privileged German am so wait
what can I do and but it was
now so economically purely theoretically
you wouldn’t have to work anymore
now after the jimdo construction
and you sell it is not yet but
you probably have when you leave
or at  the big group of us deserves a
little something, but that means
theoretically if you say to yourself that I
would like to
kitesurf in a fun way and chill out a bit for
the next few years
this
way soy and what can you
say I'm back and to be honest I have
to shake myself up first so I like
that because that was like that i  ntensive and
somehow i have a bit of the feeling that i have
seen so much and almost all around me
the other people didn't
see it
and with me that once looked at this service
what for its on two or three
so on youtube it's in there but  To
be honest, it was primarily
sold worldwide to television stations and
then translated into many languages, so
it was really super successful,
it's art, a few hundred
thousand only have it in Germany
, for example, there
are things like amazon co uk, so we'll have things there  that's
exactly what i want to say is
why did you take
away this protective layer, this this
this this this distance you have to
things that you know
are there but if you don't look at
them they don't touch you emotionally that much
and that's just for me because of
this project this protective
layer has been lost and
for me it was kl  ar I would have
believed in that I also believe there was an
innovation but it was clear to me that I
somehow couldn't
think of the next e-commerce or anything
but it was clear to me that if I did
something as an entrepreneur then I would like to work
on solving these
problems  have and then also
give time and resources to it
then in the end the best solution was to pre-build
exactly so that is of course one way to get
there i think
what the question then really bothered me
or say i was very
lucky i got to know a lamp once
and  we
had them so i
co-founded a company the white plastic that
you a piece of plastic collection
initiatives worldwide that's a
direct link to the trip so to speak
we also have an episode the playstation
stood on a lot of rubbish dumped
on beaches in indonesia and india  in
chennai and so remember a lot of guitarist
so to say well ok you can
do something there you can  yes, what to do with
it and the idea was to found white plastic
as an organization that
supports plastic collection initiatives
worldwide and basically returns the
collected plastic and
make something trivial out of it like a garbage bag from the
collected and the team
built in with the business and
during the construction process I met a
country and a
scientist and they did a
life cycle analysis for ball
plastic and that is now also a very
central component of plans
a life cycle analysis is basically
nothing else that I have the entire
ecological footprint so I look at
all the masses  energy balances over the
life cycle of a product in its entirety, i.e.
i really look at an
extraction of the raw materials how is
the processed factory how often is a
product used once - several times
how much energy do i have each
time and it also sees a meaning in life
out and all that  l interesting and
that's why in my loud in my
head it really said loudly clicked
because now life cycle analysis gives you
the opportunity to start
comparing the status quo and economy
with the idea at astana ups at once
can quantify how much better
is then  something and with plastic that was
just the first example three four
or three years four years ago where it
snowed you would say that
actually very contento deep
to transport plastic for example from haiti back
to hamburg or to europe
background hippies the
drinking water supply collapsed
during the earthquakes and
that's why there are large
amounts of plastic tubes with water in them
and people drink and
then somehow of course throw them away and
there are great qualities of the
material and it's interesting now
when I compare it to new plastic
So if I collect plastic and
then drive back tonn  Retracting
plastic has associated
emissions of 73 kilograms so not
great but if I look at
one expensive one ton of new
plastic to produce
six and a half tons of co2, so much much
more and you can see it is
actually much more
important to use a second time
having maria than minimizing transport
routes and so ultimately you
save up to 67 percent co2 with this collected plastic
compared to
the plastic reference year and that makes white
plastic now makes it bigger and now
they have also made a deal with
otto there you will be with everyone  keep up
therefore with founded he is a
responsible property i helped to
build up the team exactly that was for
me so what does basically mean a company
that is not for sale i own it
exactly that belongs to itself ok and
continue to invest
a few people the papis economy  in
private people exactly so much money is of
course
like five 600,000 gena  uen is on the right track
and what is very exciting they have
now won otto as a customer the car
will switch a large part of the shipping covers
from new plastic to wild
plastic super great and
yet it wasn’t your one
lasting story that’s me nor
would he  brought to life and then
further exactly then further so for me it
was clear I okay it's cool that to
build up for me the only question was
how can I actually make a
bigger impact than maybe building
a company and
then started thinking about
which startups
So that's how we actually promote and I think
traditionally without reproach we look purely at
monetary key figures how develop
lead to develop which is good
has great potential I think we're
now at the time when we know for
scientific reasons we
have to change our economy  we will
need 1.7 planets so if we
celebrate world overshoot day  here in
may, the day of the year when the
resources are used up that
regenerate within a year,
then we see when we look at the
world that we use 17 planets
not just one and we all
know we need an economy
within the planetary boundaries
works and what i just
noticed is that we have this
scientific evidence which startup
are actually really contributing to an
economy within the planetary
whole and which also not that it is
not part of the investment process
traditional
and that's why i
thought hey
actually we have to change exactly that
we have to make the scientific
evidence of the ideas
part of the investment process
and i talked about that with a lot of
entrepreneurs who i was able to
do my school days myself and a
lot of them said at first it's
totally true so it really has to
be in the  science  must have a
word whether will invest what yes or
no and imitators many series founders
didn't know from the time said yes
so
before would things invest and the
portfolio companies would york and the
planet promises today can't be
confused with project i
probably a few more  heard
yes but you are small and he
is still small and then you do it
founded but not alone
but then also friends or is
listened to i recognize 1 2 of his partner
friend tobias seikel for example at
the earlier you ventures was better
but
years  nick de la forge then lena title
so lena also very exciting maybe
from representatives of science applies to
the climate council of the federal government with
advice and then headed the development aid
in east africa i now
full-time at full-time and nick de la
forge is like she exactly has their have
I you experience behind has
relatively little whether you made it
w  industrial engineer deep understanding
incredibly smart so 4 we are 536
gps actually ok ok
last two is that christian chart
see entrepreneur who has a lot of experience
also in automotive automation
exactly and jan christoph gras who
founded myphotobook great change back
then been great exit really good
and then  did he invest a lot in his own book
then he actually made tim
bank big or started it with
and above all leaders for
climate action also helped found it so to
be honest
his network is very strong so her sixth that the
project was kind of waited on  and
now the fundraising is
almost over if i understand well well to
be honest it is so it
will be another half a year 34 years
i think it will be over 100
million but and 100 million in the
first project yes that's it
quite a lot of 45 1 team found but we
notice that we are really great
below  ebase has received support up to
now has been very, very
entrepreneurial many series entrepreneurs
famous athletes are in it foundations
family offices so really quite
dbs and but if you go there will also be a
classic return so as
with sales or bayernfonds too or is
it with you  downstream one
hundred percent so in
who is the investment focus for us
that we are investing in cleantech so
really a tech company and i
think
so cleantech and climate check is
that maybe it was exactly with us we
basically to
maybe explain the impact logic  we're called
plans, that means we're about the
planet and the biosphere
and what we did then it said
so ok
it's not enough to just
say yes that's kind of good for the
planet but as I said we
quantify it very strongly  So that
means we look or we just invest in
a company  if you are one of
four criteria really much
better than today's economy
that's small with medication so
reduction of greenhouse gases
measured tons of waste reduction
measured resources efficiency as a
group of indicators that can be
water consumption energy
consumption consumption of rare earths and
that  fourth biodiversity protection that
means we
look through two pairs of glasses the return
glasses that no compromises so just
like everyone else like you
we just look through
scientific glasses and look
is the impact really wants to see can be
better compared to the status quo and
calculation that and  keep investing only
then
okay that means his portfolio finds the
app made it how yes of course
quite funny
funny super cool two days ago the
day was with almost together with the
atmosphere system that was relatively big
on zdf hd even the washington post wrote
about it  the h  eats a
plant to produce erotic kerosene
exactly so we have to have there
you are there we are investing yes
and that is also a great example
because I believe
that first of all we need
climate-neutral fuels everything that
communicates aviation as an area is in
principle difficult to decarbonise
because the energy density of
batteries is not at all as high as that
of kerosene and
at this point
it makes sense to think about how
I can communicate this area and
a strategy that has now happened in europe
as well as in the usa is that a
prescribed proportion of  synthetic
fuels so in the part a share
of eight percent in the eu by 2025 of
kerosene both discussed similar guidelines three weeks ago
that
means that regulatory and
changing regulatory
will also lead to markets and
maybe if you do that now with the
return  also couples then you notice a
oh yeah okay we have to communicate all areas of the idea
, that means there will be a
regulatory idea, for example there will also be in
other areas that will benefit this type of
company and will also
allow them to really
work on it
exciting case because they are able
to produce it with
quasi david arquette co2 and green
hydrogen - send them as
synthesis gas through the reactor and in the
plants to produce a climate-neutral kerosene
petrol and diesel it's
easy for investors so
elbwiesen they say two funds  find
the more skeptical ones are different with his new one
i think i heard the episode by
hendrik brandis i
thought so at the very beginning
we went through similar experiences
i think
something happened at the beginning why  is
we had a lot of very strong cool people
at the beginning so the wheel of the
lic  htblick made me big or the
rolf letter who made trivago big with
me, people said very
early on that yes, a few million still understand each other
so they put it in
and we did a lot of
work and I
think many did  people seen hey that
really makes sense what do you know what you do
so also the scientific evidence
and I to say somehow you
scientifically but as an
indicator to find the companies that also make a
significant difference and I
think that is also the core idea of
companies  support because we
have very limited time, that means
we have to find the companies and
support the really so-called levers
up and
difficult to get that somehow possible
so yes, that more money for it
yes exactly me and I think at the very
beginning we have kulikow meters early
had and then it was a bit
yes okay that makes sense and now it
starts like this ri  really good to get a
lot of people saying hey it makes total
sense what he's doing and
now we can show the portfolio
too hey look get
these digital ones too we're seeing them and now
it's starting to develop a very positive dynamic for
us where is always
but also companies quickly come up with the idea
of investing with it or something like that or rather not s
is the private person both priva
e funds from and funds from found
tions family offices talk
lot with institutional ones so to
al bandwidth and I would say i
establishes itself very well there even
hen  ring the chance right
now you have to make the most negative one was a
bit too green to make a
gift by putting your money in there
is
for many also soya will do which is good
because I think you
have a better one now or  sustainable
investment approach 90 most of the time
we speak long and well with all apps
and we have to set
the rule for ourselves  frankly we don't want to be
a fig leaf for someone somewhere,
we want to find people
who have a real
interest in changing where they say it's
part of my strategy to get in this
direction i can't
generalize but we have
really good conversations with them  who also
long to make sure that we go in
this direction picture well that's
how we were allowed to invest a very, very
small amount here
also knows a bit but
nevertheless the question is important
and now we understand the money
comes from because we  have to work hard
to get the money to convince the people
you can
imagine now the sonata deal flow
so where does the tlz come from if you have
done other things so far how
do you get to know people who can do such
synthetic
dyes
the a tec also got a link about
german  en turner price but maybe
a step back
if you had the feeling you could see a lot and that shows i think you can make
the apps out as the limited partners who
have invested with us, there are just
a lot of well-known entrepreneurs and
that means that the  forward super deal
flow to us they actually say
hey look here
you can figure it out that means we get 50 percent of very
prequalified good deals that we can
then look at really coolly
and then also a large number of
people who have them apply like that  and i
think the competition is high as
i mean i actually had
really big drawers a few
months ago a podcast with ashton kutcher he
told me that now a
little tip how to do it i hear
a lot of small tag in the environment then  it's
starting, thank goodness, but there are
and how many cool 100 entrepreneurs
like you in the
end the feeling  you are also
part of a total wave and i think
that's exactly what is needed. that
's exactly what we
believe that we want to be a cooperative
player in this market,
so maybe one thing still flows at the
end of an investment process
not only money for us, but we
do a life cycle analysis
and can tell you a few games
right away, so to speak, we
always compare the status quo with the idea of
tup and can quantify how m
ch better something is and that is espec
ally for an early phase startup  what's
going on right now a huge huge value
because the ultimate external places
have their own idea
someone comes and says so jakob mahl now
let's quantify exactly how it
actually works and then you can
prove what effects your
idea has and that's something  which is very
valuable for these people because they have
an exam pretty much next next ha
but that also means that I
honestly didn't anticipate
running off it also means that
other top tier wies are very happy
to have us there because we also have
evidence for them through
science, so I would also
benedicto spiels still employed that
firmly a scientist that we do
this in this type of
quantification for the investors
that sounds a bit in a positive
sense like in the past i had my
buddy pulled real estate that now
by giving people the
chance to evaluate or arte  cost
appraisal makes what is a house worth
and have that everyone wants to know and
then he had the addresses and
could you so yes i do the
free evaluation for you and then
invest again afterwards afterwards has
already marketed a house further
so it’s just the way it is  is super complex so
a life cycle analysis depending on
which database you have in the
sometimes 100, 150, 200
working hours go into it so it's really
something when you buy it on the open market
, it's 50, 60, 70 thousand euros
to have such an analysis, that means
it's not even like that and
it's also on the  payroll on the
other hand i'm convinced
that we have to do this in order to be able to make better
investment decisions in the
future was because i think
we just have to support the companies that
really
make a significant difference and i don't think
we're allowed to guess or just
guess  the business know
look at it but we need the other
component is there in say we company
wants says you now have unicorn
potential this you have already seen
all this a company that is actually
in the portfolio that is
insanely excited this major time the
senses is a software business  they
are able to use
a picture of metals to show
which components are in a product  kt
with and to say from which factories
come so real data are gods
so tie a lot of databases
with constantine gens that means you
are able to say he is this
car sitting or this turbine or can
and this
wind blade from one of a
wind turbine
where do the individual components come from in
which factories were they produced
what co2 footprint do you have through the
linking of the entire logistics through
to the energy mix in the last
in the individual so that means this
system can also be managed during a design
process that to sort of
exactly these emissions are still calculated
, so there reduced exactly
calculated first and then
you can reduce them and
we are a lot of people in the
co2 accounting space, so a
small number of them are planning
normatively, which everyone reports as if yes for the
company and what is super
difficult  it for all is actually
the scope three missions of the supply chain
z  u calculate and then they come in
and are able to do that and are able to
do that in the
design process as well, so that you are then
able to design a product better and think about where it is
namely not my components at all of
course you have to pay and i
have works so see and find
that super exciting because of course it is
key technology i need
if i need my supply chains better that
the company has been in this now
how much
we are worth  because it washes in quite early
now because there is
no official rating they
will tear at some point and then there will be a
big thought then it will
somehow have single-digit values at first, so t
o speak, but let's say the poten
ial of what you see and we'll look at so
e  blatant big corporations
want to talk to right now so it's
really your bet
so the next thing I have to do at montech
could only come in the climate area i
would say
it doesn't have to i don't speak for playtech at all
but i think if we don't
manage to get the unicorns to come from the
cleantech area
then we're perfect well then we
have to get it done  that the people
build the companies
that make a huge impact that must also be the monetary
winners are actually if you
look at them biotech germany is
now quite strong so for example it was
also raised by
the founders of course but also by investors
there are these strict ones  both brothers and
then there are somehow i think
mr. hopp biotech investing there are also, let's say,
monster entrepreneurs like the strikes
or how hopp so multiple billionaires
who now say hey biotech is also
really cool but i'm doing it now in the
cleantech area there are such  people
i think it's getting more and more
so that you say yes there are more f  onds go
in the direction because before
that it's still early trying
to say your stream were move okay beyond the
watch we're going in billions
now you just can't afford it 100 years ago
and it totally so
i hope the sea will  worth who
have to be so it's totally clear
but so hopp doesn't speak
exactly yet either belongs to it a
bit o'clock in the end bullish so that
's the problem with saying would
you solve that your trip there made many
seen now the talks are alive again
she's the  technology
is just an incentive for hendrik brandis
podcast he was very bullish that it will
be solved as you
say
it has to be solved otherwise let's
say this trip showed me
and i think we in germany
just haven't been really affected by climate change
i think so  of course,
through this flood disaster, times
have found out how canon
people were directly affected
and if you stop  so on the
trip i just saw how other
people lead other regions to
the effect much more strongly and
maybe bullish is the wrong
word then so when you see which effects
is hard and how expensive it will be
if you don't get it under control  so it can
be much more expensive than if we do something
if we do it and people
also follow a lot of what is coming galloway,
for example, who says is quite
negative that can
not be solved well anyway that the
social structures
we are heading towards the catastrophe
there are also theses why that
could be the case that you can stop the problem is only
very limited where may or
delay yes
and then there is an elite somewhere
on earth that gets along quite well but a lot
of people are not like that is also a scenario
i  think it's the worst case
scenario what then what happens then
they love protect each other and of
course isolate themselves i think that's it  not a
scenario that we want in
i think the whole thing is of course
not a binary decision as we see
it there is not one complete work
or we don't make it at all but
it's about somehow reducing every tenth of a degree what we
manage that
means i think it's relatively
there is no alternative that we try everything to go in this direction and of course i see the whole thing in a larger context, i.e. how innovative strength and our entrepreneurship can bring a large part of the solution but it is
also about regulatory
and politics if we choose  a
government that, how do we manage to be able to support
this transformation towards
radicalization in society
as well,
that means that is an interaction,
that is, at teachers’ day what
legislation is there in the future,
which fields will open up and where
start-ups can jump in  once able to
build a profitable business I
think  e that's more the question
is now it's going well that's how you proved
your investment makes more sense for the first time in the monastery
next few months further
investments and then it takes a lot of 56
years until you then at some point
then at best start again
exactly so it's closed for then
ten years that means  the first five
years you invest the next five
years you invest exactly and that
is the normal logic so then
at some point you will travel ahead of the next one and
above all those who support it
perfectly on the way back then and what
so i don’t hear  again
there are so and so many iks on our of
doubling or tripling i
think from 4x is already very good
he you imagine that too yes
definitely so i think
the same claim at the point also
because the tech companies we do
so we see that major normal
pcs are moving into these areas as well as
deals that we can already see that there is
me  same logic that there that there that
takes place and if you now say
ok I think that’s awesome so I believe in the team
if you listen to it well
it’s really super staffed so from the
various skills that you
bring david to the event I think it makes it  am
then you can somehow get in touch with me
or with you or would you
also somehow leave three yes ok ok with
pleasure yes then where we hope that we don't
get in touch with each other maybe know
that you somehow he is only now
in the server completes the first  first
first funds and then just right how
many again of course we have
now made five two more already
decided they will come out in the near future
right now always a few
thousand
more actually so now in the
first things we did a little
less but  normally
investing 12 million would be at the
beginning you don't
need a lot more money in the end than
ever before  now if you can do
things on the internet he was then just a
bit what is skillful then sure
that the marketing money or salaries
with you must now also be worthy hardware
and research and susanne yes exactly so
music we so exactly the thesis we
need software  and hardware upgrade of
the world so with software alone I'm
not the world that communicates or
creates as an economy
that means we do both and
typically go a little earlier in
what software things need hardware things a little later
and of course
it's capital-intensive is
n't a question of
everything  sure so cool project of
course the diverse so in hamburg is to
know we here but very dangerous
janneck
werr defense by the countries exactly so lena
lives with her family in
south africa stoffel and so jan christoph gras and
nick they are in berlin we are
here in hamburg  i'm a lot of berlin of
course because a lot
happens hey  We are completely digitally
positioned, which also makes total sense.
Ultimately, I did the fundraising even when
he was in the pandemic. That means of
course many people were so quick
or a lot ourselves when we bought a few
clothes and actually I'm
not already in winter either  from time to time in
south africa but i try to reduce it very much actually so that means 345 big wings years ago less am here i would say yes there and back flight south africa and otherwise i
have now had one to portugal at a
conference where clearly with  honda
actually came together and us
investors and fauna but what what is there
to say best thing to do now but i
don't have the money to
invest in it i think the way is
right how can i support the
way with my own life
so what we  it's good to say less
flying or maybe it's
better to reduce it or because
you want to do your things i now beit too
ask what should you contribute
exactly i think the biggest levers
are actually politics so i think
there is a publishing wave or yes
so green so in any case choose people
who are not on the side of the
preventers and brakes but
people who are this transformation  but
i think since every 14 athletes is important
yes
that's true i think i would
look at it we've been moving in this direction for a long time
and it's not just
doing it now so there's such a distorted image
now getting in a suit is ok should
i get one now too  bright spot here
already discussed each other as a partner where
i always say there can't hurt
so was red-green on the storm so
generally green electricity really good if
you come maybe you have to do
classics but first politics and you have to get
politically involved for the
framework conditions that is i think  the
really big lever so that's really
challenging that's going in this direction
framework conditions have to change
Because our consumption is so I think it's totally
right to talk about personal consumption and
our CO2 footprint,
but the general framework conditions are
the more important ones and that's why it's
also important if we have to choose here
on the nuclear power side inside also in the
camp which is green  absolutely no
nuclear power i wouldn't say that i
think we have to see
what are the weakest
problems of our time and how
do we get there if we can do it without nuclear power
then it's good but how, for
example, can we believe we can do it  the
investment in geothermal energy area, where it is
about making geothermal energy more accessible as a reason for
energy source in
many regions always my then only in
regions with
tectonic plates in berlin like
iceland like california where this kind of
heat is directly under the surface
if you can create such energy sources
to be made accessible in many places
according to grundlastfähi  ge
things then it can also be something like
nuclear power so he says but actually
says yes everyone knows how
you do the usa
also bill gates or something like that explicitly
invest in nuclear power and only then is it
important without that it won't work only
in germany here  are there a
lot of things right now with the green ones they
see it differently yes exactly i exactly i
think there is more there is a
sequence of problems and in
my opinion decarbonization
is the most important thing that we make quick
progress and i don't know for  have the
luxury of doing without it in the long
term okay but that's
also a clear announcement that
somehow with all ecological
awareness that you now only really
credibly hate and live that he
still the atomic issue is
probably solved the current case yes
exactly so and  we have we also
need other technologies, so geothermal
energy has the potential
to replace that to a large extent  en so i think we
have to make the right
decisions that we communicate really quickly
ok ok
then you can come up with a few tangible
thoughts many thanks friedel fürst come
by and also many consequently we are
observing that so to speak we
haven’t made it up to now that’s
super
nice the conversation with friedl  and now, as
bonus material, a short update from
a close friend or a
befriended brand of a company you
do a lot to me, namely the
colleagues from fritz kola also from
hamburg, who founded a cult brand from the city of
mirco again a few years ago, at the
end of 2018  year
with the podcast was a guest the whole
story told me
that he had written a book
and babies fritz kola team current
one kroner and delivery services weighed so
this goes nicholas niko thanks for the
invitation great just before christmas is
running yes despite  All because you think
yes if you ever  now
thinks about the beverage industry but it will be
difficult yes i don't want to complain at all
so of course it was is would it
is still challenging
but our employees
really pulled along well and the women and
men fritz kola would have done the
work forever  they postponed their vacations
or pulled
them earlier or added them later so all the
megapixels really had it all so
far we're doing extremely well
together it was but that sure
help such a small thing get on a train because the problem is
huge  so it felt like the gastronomy
was at festivals where
football is big, things aren't like that, yes,
the problem was they were overwhelmingly big
with us, so we are a gastronomy,
we are more present in the guest so
if of course all our
customers are easy to do  that's
bad, only
some of our customers themselves would
have caused trouble
insofar as ka  nn just a word not
long ago the biggest that the company
meanwhile we are about 280 people
okay okay so it's not a small
shop either and has always been the small ones yes
but it has improved in the last year
with your torches yes we are
constantly developing so  not only about about was
still heads about even more Fritzen
but also about about about performance about
your about ideas about
internationalization also knows then
you've thought about how now in all
the turbulence
I'm writing a book
yes I've already fully booked the book
[music  ]
but I picked up speed 217 and
then I started and now
this year is august it also took a while
to finish it was quite a
while so what we have a lot of time and I
if you are still not
really a part of this classic  from these
thematic founding systems where you
know okay you do now because sees
round
I don't know because the usa and then
we pull it through  h then there is
somehow an exit or something you have
already taken a completely different path or you at the
beginning as a couple and a completely different
trip agreed and i have the
feeling you are not really in the
berlin scene that is an issue
yes me  I think we're just not a tech
company, a bit of classic
cola and lemonade and with us it's
just
that, of course, it should simply be
a different approach and everyone
's motivation is also described in the book
that we do our thing
and if we had to do ongoing
financing rounds  we'll
somehow run into people and I
think we
're just up for it we never wait that's why we're
still a real one not only in the company
but also never in the company and that's what
makes us different, maybe they were
a bit different and  we
never had this drive
either, but we plan to exit that's not our thing
insofar as the story of f
ritz kola make sense for interested people
if you want to look at a different
model from startup was
just doing two things
differently okay okay and market activity that
's now the book isn't but what
are you also known for that you
brand-wise
again and again  somehow does unusual things
with st pauli the trip is
also a fritz kola trip the usa
also travels a bit the fritz kola
trip so look out for a
partner with whom you can do things together
legendary your face on the logo
years  long there is usually so much more we
are looking forward to the next festival season
which hopefully it will take place so
where everyone where the entire industry is currently
preparing where we are
simply planning a lot of new things are also in very good
talks
as let me say a bit of an analog
brand  who we are with our
glass bottles, of course we have to
take place in the ice age where it is
relevant  for our fans all about music and
culture all about for which things just
happen with happening always
highlights so probably says okay because
not grown up or is it more rock am
ring or is he what it is at
the festival has to surprise like the
still in the talks but i
think there wo
n't be anything more with the big things again okay okay and
accompanied by the book so i know where you
have it it's completely black so
if you're looking in bookstores or on
amazon that's clear too
is very lovingly
designed by the way in the same design
company that also made him
so everything is in hamburg they also do a lot for
us so the
rocketlink great design agency makes itself for
hamburg musicians i think then
a regular one because i do the records
and stuff  what if I believe
you always promise me that
again during the booklet with all the
work or that's to die for  n
good really so that means it's worth booking
not just the text alone but
also because of the design say we
're some then too it's
very personal impressions and pictures
of you so children's pictures well it's a
story it's my fritz kola
story  Written from my
perspective actually
it is very personal but
founding a company is also
very personal that unfortunately fits well
written I wrote it together with the
ghostwriter with whom oliver gives
the [ __ ] and because of course I can
tell the story but
I can now  experts don't have to write
for it and he did it
cleverly it is written so
if it's my text but the
ghostwriter is just a very good trainer
in
the author who also includes his
German and
to pack that into a text that makes sense  what would
appreciate how many people or what
would be success so i am i am yes we
are  Yes, because it was also favorable that I just
found out close together that the
book was published by a 1 publishing house, my
economics office is called it,
I also have a book, this heart, which is
great,
I had a print run of 10,000, hope
that it sells what you
are  already gone with us now in the
second edition of
course the beatles
congratulations
yes we were super happy it was also
published in english okay
that won't sell that quickly
because we spoke and are
just that but we also want to
internationalize and of
course we want to  also our our
coming the customers just bring up the
story so what now why is fritz doing
so now in france or in poland
or the baltic states where is the book
called fritz versus
goliath then is the existing
beverage industry yes that is
real but in  his book i mean i did
n't manage to earn money with it countries is
probably au  ch not or
no then it's time that's
not the point yet do you think it was also
four euros more expensive at least that was it
was something else mainz was
recommended to me so happy that i counted
on it so it costs 20 euros
1 yes and  that's somehow yes
that looks very nice on every shelf
so it might be good today if
the podcast comes is probably
christmas then at short notice but who
wants to talk now wants to be
inspired who's up for fritz
versus goliath by mirko wolf wiegard
everywhere where there are books  and if you do
n't feel like it yet, everywhere there is a podcast
there is episode 170 from december
2018 we will certainly
do an update in the next few months and then
hear how many books you sold how
well they sold on gorillas and so
on many many thanks for that
for all those who have
personally decided to continue their education in 2022
, i would have something, namely
h  But we finally have an area with
us Mr. Location and, among other things,
there are so-called deep dive courses
and you deepen your knowledge of very specific topics to
really get ahead, e.g.
in the area of seo in the area of instagram marketing i
the area of digital analytix in the area of e-mai
-marketing you can
learn a lot within a few
hours a lot of added value for
yourself and then also for
your employer who wants to do it
intensively practical either live and of
course also digitally with a
personal participant with a certificate
at the end who can take a look at what
you do  there offer and abyss comes the pdk
and currently there is the
voucher code deep dive 22 10 on all
courses so again uhrwerk point comes
maybe stayed visit
[music]
this podcast picture produced by
popstars
at mr